this video is brought to you by appsumo
the leading digital marketplace for
entrepreneurs
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
this episode is going to be a short one
my apartment flooded last week so
sorting all of that out took some time
and production has slowed as a result
the smartphone industry is massive
each and every year the revenue from
smartphone sales is about 400 billion us
dollars
and over a billion units are sold each
year
google who owns the android ecosystem is
taking a page out of apple's handbook
they're going to be designing their own
in-house smartphone chip
it will debut in google's upcoming pixel
6 smartphone
later this year later on in the episode
we'll take a look at how new google
research
is using ai to design computer chips in
just a few hours
whereas a human expert would have taken
months it's pretty interesting
so let's take a
cool fusion look
most android phones including google's
own pixel line have relied on the chip
designer qualcomm
for clarity's sake qualcomm an american
company designs the chips
but the chips themselves are actually
built by samsung and tsmc
the latest move from google looks to
remove itself from qualcomm completely
the new in-house processor codenamed
google silicon 101 or otherwise known as
whitechapel will power google's upcoming
phones as mentioned
but is also expected to feature in
future chromebooks
samsung has teamed up with google to
build their custom chip
and this makes sense as they already
build chips for qualcomm but also use
their own custom chips in their
smartphone sold outside the us
these samsung chips are known as the
exynos series
google ceo sunder pichai stated that
google planned to seed more investment
into hardware
but as it stands google hasn't invested
enough in their semiconductor business
to be competitive just yet although
they're choosing to hone their focus
in an area where they can obtain a
competitive advantage against the major
players
and this area is ai
[Music]
google is already good at using ai to
enhance image quality
the camera hardware on their phones
hasn't been updated in years
but manages to keep up with the
competition solely thanks to the ai
within their software
a chip with a focus on ai hardware
acceleration could lead to even better
photos
using machine learning improved color
science image stabilization
and even audio processing is all
possible
a report from axios mentions the white
chapel chip will have a dedicated area
for google assistant processing
this is to improve performance and
always-on capabilities
with google's lambda coming on the
software side this could be interesting
for those of you who don't know google
lambda is going to incorporate the
latest in ai language processing
so the google assistant can understand
context and have conversations with its
users
here's an example today i'm excited to
share our latest breakthrough
in natural language understanding lambda
since designed to converse on any topic
let's listen to a conversation the team
had with pluto
a few days ago i'm so curious about you
i sense your excitement
ask me anything tell me what i would see
if i visited
you would get to see a massive canyon
some frozen icebergs
geysers and some craters hey i was
wondering have you ever had any visitors
yes i have had some the most notable was
new horizons the spacecraft that visited
me
that must have been exciting the team
that created new horizons was very
excited to see me
i also sent them back a picture of
myself since i had not been seen up
close before
that's so great what else do you wish
people knew about you
i wish people knew that i am not just a
random ice ball
i am actually a beautiful planet thanks
for talking with me
anytime i am always open for people to
chat
i hope you have a great day because none
of the responses were predefined
and lambda is able to carry a
conversation
no matter what we talk about lambda plus
custom hardware
could make for a next level ai assistant
potentially even offline
[Music]
so why do this in the first place one of
the biggest advantages of building an
in-house chip over buying an external
one off the shelf is the tight
integration between software and
hardware
the software knows exactly what it's
going to be working with so it can be
more efficient
this should improve the end user's
experience
in the earlier days of smartphones heavy
optimization from apple
controlling both the software and
hardware allowed the iphone to operate
smoothly and provide an arguably better
user experience
despite being woefully underpowered and
limited in features compared to the
competition of the time
another benefit of google building their
own chips is a reduction in production
cost
now instead of acquiring processors from
external providers like qualcomm
who themselves need to make a profit
google can design the chips themselves
and if they choose they can use the
money saved to either cut down costs
or use the money to improve other areas
of the phone
so what can we expect from google's
upcoming white chapel chip
google's decision to separate from
qualcomm is an interesting one because
it's actually going to look like there's
going to be a performance drop when
compared to the best that qualcomm has
to
offer the new white chapel chip is going
to be behind apple's a14 bionic
the snapdragon 8 and definitely not to
mention the m1
according to wccf tech we know from the
internal documents and other leaks that
the white chapel chip will have an 8
core arm design with 3 clusters
much like the samsung exynos 2100 and
while efficient compared to the
company's previous manufacturing
techniques
the google chip will most certainly be a
step behind the competition nine to five
google states that the predicted
performance will be similar to the
qualcomm snapdragon 765
already used in the pixel 5. to the
layman
this just means that the google chip
will have middle of the road performance
interestingly according to the economic
times a team of google researchers are
working on an ai model that allows chip
design to be performed by artificial
intelligence
the new ai method utilizes past
experience to become better and faster
at solving new instances of the problem
the google team writes in the paper for
the scientific journal
nature quote our method was used to
design the next generation of google's
artificial intelligence accelerators
and has the potential to save thousands
of hours of human effort
for each new generation according to the
team
in about six hours the model could
generate a design that optimizes the
placement of different components on the
chip
quote in under six hours our method
automatically generates chip floor plans
that are superior
or comparable to those produced by
humans in all key metrics
including power consumption performance
and chip
area to achieve this
the google team used a data set of 10
000 chip layouts for a machine learning
model which was then trained with
reinforcement learning
anna goldie research scientist at google
brain explains
quote our reinforcement learning agents
generates chip layouts in just a few
hours
whereas human experts can take months
despite many decades and a mature
industry
chip design has resisted automation
requiring months of intense effort by
physical design engineers to produce
manufacturable layouts
so this latest development only
published last month is extremely
interesting
so we're going to have to wait and see
if google will make up for lost time by
using ai
in their upcoming chip designs it's also
important to note that with the global
semiconductor chip shortage
google might have a tough time actually
getting these chips built
and if you want to learn more on the
shortage and what exactly is being
affected
you can check out my video on that also
if you're one of those people who are
wary of google
would you trust them designing their own
chip for their smartphones
are you concerned about security issues
such as backdoors
feel free to discuss in the comments
section below
i just want to thank today's sponsor
appsumo as
creators and entrepreneurs we wear a lot
of hats
social media project management sales
accounting
copywriting web development and the list
goes on
appsumo wants to make your life easier
as the leading digital marketplace for
entrepreneurs
appsumo is the best way to automate all
the tasks that come with running a
business
i just picked up this ai writing tool
called writer it's normally 600
but i got it for under forty dollars it
allows you to auto write heaps of stuff
with just a few keywords
i thought to try it out for a youtube
description and title just to see what
it did
and it does work and i think it's a
great seed for creativity that you can
build off
you can also use it for blogs emails
business pictures
even social media and much more i
actually personally do think it's cool
to see ai language processing being used
in such a natural way
as a special bonus to the channel
appsumo is giving twenty dollars and
free credits to the first 500 people who
click the link in the description
okay so that's it from me thanks for
watching
if you've just arrived at this channel
and want to see anything on science
technology business or history feel free
to subscribe to cold fusion
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's new thinking
you